- C'est un moment historique
de réconciliation, c'est
un moment que tout le monde
mais on vit dans
un contexte de pandémie.
- À l'approche de la visite
du pape François à Québec,
Judith Gagnon lance un appel
à la prudence pour les aînés
qui envisagent de participer
à l'événement.
JUDITH GAGNON, Table de concert.
des personnes aînées, Cap.-Nat.
- Il faut vraiment faire
attention. Il y a des petits
gestes qui sont importants.
On va être plusieurs
pour aller voir le pape.
Mettez votre masque,
essayez d'être moins tassés
avec d'autres personnes.
Puis, les organisateurs :
prenez soin des gens.
- Je suis un peu inquiet.- L'inn
partage l'avis de Judith Gagnon.
Selon lui, les personnes
vulnérables devront se protéger
pour éviter que l'événement,
auquel devraient assister
des dizaines de milliers
de personnes, ne devienne
une source d'éclosions.
Dr MATHIEU SIMON, pneumologue
et chef des soins
- Ils sont peut-être âgés,
ils sont peut-être vulnérables.
Ce serait très dommage
qu'ils obtiennent
la recon
qu'ils souhaitent et puis
qu'ils reviennent de là
avec une reconnaissance,
mais surtout avec un virus
qui risque de leurue de leurue r
beaucoup de trouble.
- Une inquiétude qui n'est pas
partagée par tout le monde.
- S'il y a trop de monde,
me reculer, mais
j'irai pas dans la foule.
C'est sûr et certain.
- Mais vous allez venir
voir le pape quand même?
même!
- Je suis contente
que le pape vienne...
et puis il faut que les gens
se comportent de façon prudente,
donc ça m'inquiète pas.
- On met nos masques partout.
Ça fait qu'il n'y a pas
de problèmes. Pour nous autres,
on n'est pas trop inquiets.
- Comme partout dans
la province, la COVID-19
est en progression
dans la Capitale-Nationale.
Et la pression est forte
pour les services hospitaliers.
NANCY HOGAN, prés. Syndicat
interprofessionnel du CHU Québec
- C'est sûr que de voir
des rassemblements
200 000-300 000 personnes sur
les plaines, que ça va être des
personnes âgées, c'est sûr que
c'est inquiétant. Puis, c'est
sûr que c'est ça, on n'a p
à l'heure actuelle, nos urgences
débordent déjà, puis on va
en rajouter encore. C'est sûr
que oui, c'est inquiétant.
- Malgré tout,
selon les dernières
données disponibles, parmi
les 274 personnes hospitalisées
en lien avec la COVID-19 dans
la grande région d
seules huit se trouvent
aux soins intensifs.
Ici Flavie Sauvageau,
Radio-canada, Qué